hugues donc jean marie villemin a été
puni pour le meurtre de bernard laroche
mais il sera libre bientôt il a déjà
passé trente trois mois en préventive en
rendant leur verdict cinq ans de prison
dont un avec sursis
les jurés de la coupe de la cour
d'assises de la côte d'or non suivis ni
l'avocat général qui réclamait une peine
de 10 ans minimum
li la défense qui souhaitait
l'acquittement reportage d'isabelle
style et hervé poggio sous bonne escorte
jean marie villemin retourne en prison
cerib le mans a battu les jurés n'ont
pas répondu à ses supplications ne me
séparait pas de christine et de mes
enfants avait t-il sangloter ce matin il
espérait encore ce soir il sera seul
face à sa douleur ses seuls aussi que
christine bilma rentrer chez elle elle a
longuement pleuré et toujours le même
scénario les mêmes excès une dernière
fois
m garraud a défendu ce couple comme ses
propres enfants selon ses termes
certes il n'a pas obtenu l'acquittement
mais le verdict marque la fin de 9 ans
de calvaire pour les deux époux jean
marie et christine dont 10 sont
effondrés ils se sont retrouvés dans la
petite salle ils sont tombés dans les
bras l'un de l'autre et c'est toujours
comme je les dis l'amour qu'ils se
portent plein à l'autre il leur a permis
supporter ces épreuves
mais maintenant y voient la fin du
tunnel et l'espoir devant de tout au
long de ce procès marie-ange laroche
avait l'impression qu'on assassine et
son et une seconde fois pour elle le
verdict sonne comme une réhabilitation
en étant jean marie villemin en prison
ça démontre l'innocence de berlin
jean marie villemin portant en prison
c'est parce qu'ils rendre l'opéra misant
pont la justice et dean les dernières
images d'un tourbillon judiciaire qui a
duré neuf ans tous espère maintenant que
ce verdict apaisera jamais les passions
dominique verdeilhan vous avez suivi ce
procès de bout en bout on peut dire que
ce verdict mitigé illustre une nouvelle
fois la complexité de cette affaire
whipple mais on peut dire aussi qu'il
s'agit là d'un verdict d'apaisement pour
un procès sans vérité sans vérité parce
que un acquittement aurait été en
quelque sorte une condamnation posthume
de bernard laroche
en revanche une lourde peine aurait
laissé supposer que la cour d'assises de
la côte d'or aurait plutôt penché pour
l'innocence de bernard laroche
apaisement parce que la partie civile
craignait l'acquittement qui aurait été
pour elle selon elle un permis de tuer
apaisement aussi parce que c'est un
verdict qu'accepte la défense qui vous
l'avez dit ne va pas se pourvoir en
cassation
neuf ans ça suffit nous a dit tout à
l'heure m garraud et par ce choix jean
marie villemin
mais en quelque sorte un point final à
cette procédure une volonté d'en finir
après un long combat contre cette
catastrophe judiciaire une volonté aussi
d'en finir donc après ce verdict
consensuel un verdict dont on peut dire
en quelque sorte qu'il réunit les deux
familles dans un relatif sentiment
justice dominique jean marie villemin
retourne en prison ce soir mais il en
sortira très bientôt à quel moment à
votre avis alors écoutez on rentre là
dans une logique arithmétique que jean
marie villemin a effectué presque trois
ans de détention provisoire il lui reste
à purger 13 mois et demi la loi autorise
dans les jours prochains à demander une
libération conditionnelle
la décision est du ressort d'une
commission d'application des peines
cette décision pourrait être prise soit
à la fin de l'année soit début d'année
prochaine
les avocats en tout cas de jean marie
villemin et de christine
villemin ne cachez pas ce soir leur
espoir de voir bientôt jean marie
villemin retrouvé la liberté pour
essayer aussi de commencer une autre vie
avec une double image en quelque sorte
celle d'un père inconsolable et celle
donnée ce soir par ce verdict ici à
dijon
celle d'un assassin aux circonstances
atténuantes
merci dominique en âge